hi everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm
Michael Medina in here were to talk
about the season two premiere of arrow
back CW's hit series and get back some
DC Comics some goodness its back a
episode started off interesting I mean I
did expect to go back on the island but
it wasn't a flashback Lee briefly yeah
that was I think it's a little bit of
foreshadowing too because we know that
our seal that conflict whatever happen
on the island is was resolved or
something happened because he just went
back there for a little vacation I guess
cuz he's overcome by all the emotions of
it was Dino his buddy Diane yeah season
you know finale is pretty rough but yeah
I like it wit started I like the way how
I me seek Diggle and you see just like
trying to convince him to come back to
write you know to to Star City and
everything and said it was good yeah I
mean like a typical kind of season from
your fashion we're getting just getting
you know bacala mated seeing what's
going on with everybody where's
everybody at right now I do like I like
that you know we had Oliver had a little
you no conscience issue I mean he's not
sure exactly what he's doing he's kind
of he's feel bad because it is Tommy
Diane yeah well he's also questioning
just his purposes I know good you know
when it comes to murder and he does want
to be known for that and you know he
mentions in the episode how you know
it's like he's dis honoring his memory
by Bryant inning the murder which I just
has to stop doing it I mean I haven't
like that Felicity even call them out
and you know said that you know I don't
mean to be the intensive one here but
who cares you know that you've killed
people before and you know I think it's
interesting I mean it's nice to see the
team back you know we're also introduced
to see what Roy Harper has a red hood
yes we know he's red arrow I hope you
know knows he's not ready oh yeah but we
hope he's gonna be so he's easy will
he's doing some visually I work himself
yeah he's amazed a little rough around
the edges maybe I mean last season the
same thing he was just like hell bent on
trying to you know change up his
attitude and everything kind of like
take the law into his own hands and then
we also see like some hood phonetics
yeah it's almost like a remind me a
little bit of was it the dark knight
yeah the dark knight knew the dark
knight right we're Batman encounters
those vigilantes that are like you know
he's trying to inspire people to do good
things and these guys are kind of
following the hood but they're taking a
little too far right you know
they're really embracing the whole like
murdering aspect of everything and uh
yes that was little crazy and let's talk
about these guys just walking into every
place I mean these guys are not ninjas
they're not though they don't have the
hoods training they don't you know but
it was funny because like Oliver's in
that meeting and these guys just
randomly again come up in the elevator
walk out full gear right this murder the
mayor kill the mayor a dinner party they
just uh you know they'd go to middle of
a nightclub like is anybody watching
these guys they're not like specially
trained there just like some people who
you know lost some family members now
they want revenge but I mean it was good
i mean we needed something for Oliver to
get with the suit back on something it
was a good i thought was a good first
episode yeah way to set up definitely on
the upcoming season um you know at the
end to we get a nice little glimpse a
little cameo yeah I was I didn't think
gonna see Black Canary that soon that
came yeah that was cool it was nice and
short but sweet right I mean we know and
I know those of you you know like and I
read comic books and all those you lot
out there read comic books you're
familiar with air probably two more than
we are I know we will talk about summer
glau in a little bit with her character
I know some of you like oh she's in the
comics and I don't really know arrow
comics that well but I wonder how cuz
obviously speedy and Roy Harper are
supposed to be the same yeah and they
split those two people in half with Roy
Harper is his own guidance pd's and
sister so what is who's Black Canary
gonna be is she gonna be the character
she is in the cob book or she gonna be
maybe Laurel sister come back I wonder i
don't know i'm thinking that might be
the case because that was kind of like
you know focal point up from last season
right you know when uh you know uh
laurels mother and right yeah you know
they're convinced that are you know her
sisters alive so I'm thinking that might
be a thing right i mean that's
interesting i mean and of course do we
have to get back to the introduction of
summer glau isabel say India or now she
wrote yet I've always four names I mean
it's like we talk about this later
scarlett johansson to the avengers
Romanoff no accent but you know for
anyway but besides that summer glau is
on the show i love summer glau she was
good on this she was good as good I mean
she is just play huge role in this
episode at least she's just known for
playing geek roles ya ever in Sarah you
know Sarah Connor Chronicles you ever
and Firefly I mean she's just just known
for those kind of iconic roles in the
gate yeah we don't want to mention the
cake let's not mention that I got
cancelled too soon hopefully arrow has
nice long life I have it
glad to see summer in there and so of
course we have to mention this we have
mentioned the romance oh yeah there's a
lot of possibilities for him I mean
Laurel said that you know she feels a
little guilty there's gonna be friends
yeah but this Felicity that that
relationship can never be perfect in the
firm no no it's too much drama boy yeah
yeah I mean we have Felicity though
we'll enjoys watching him work out that
we've learned you know did a little
machine that he doesn't pull a bar and
then of course with summer glau on the
picture now it's it's something's gonna
go yeah like days like looks are gonna
be seen a lot more of each other it's
like oh yes we are yeah so this show was
good i mean it's got all the elements of
course got to see it just like I mean
what do you think about the moment it
was a little hallmark II but what the
moment between me know Oliver's mom and
his sister yeah it was yeah we had to
make their peace yeah absolutely i'm
gonna happen it was you knows good mom
is the money that I guess II know needed
to happen to you know I mean she can
stay mad at her mom for long all right
was a little cheese it was nice
especially I mean this shows good i mean
its CW but i think it does above and
beyond what i would expect from a cibc
like i know you Mike was commenting
during the episode we're watching it was
just saying that how almost like Bourne
Identity it is in the actions yeah
that's one of things I love about it
like again that's seen when the the the
hood phonetic right vacuum in the office
and everything and there's a scene when
he's like holding on a Felicity need to
you know jump from one window down to
the Nexus I was cool and just like all
the fighting elements and stuff it's fun
it's entertaining right and we get on
with this but the titles episode was
aptly named city of heroes you know
perfect title because we get the
instruction of Black Canary already in
the first I don't think we're gonna see
her till later we know that I guess I'm
gonna start looking ahead now we know
the flash is gonna be coming because
he's going to spin off at some point I'd
imagine it right I'm halfway through the
season might seem right of course we'll
get married but net now from Spartacus
who was a death stroke who's now gonna
be serious regular he's on the show so I
mean it is a city of heroes we're seeing
everybody I think it's gonna be a good
season i think is I'm really looking
forward to I'm looking forward to seeing
what they do with the red hood or right
you're gonna call right you know I mean
that's gonna be fun and getting down to
who you know the hell up like any right
yeah and what name is Oliver gonna play
I mean the answer what name do you want
to go by and you just looked at the
arrow is it just gonna be arrow it's
gonna be the green arrow can't even do
that with the comic book rights on how
that works I mean who knows what his
name was gonna pick I'm guessing it
there
I mean green arrow might sound will
cheese like hey I'm the green arrow I do
I feel a cheesy yellow girl works it
works so it's modern it's a tip you know
I mean this is the CW we gotta do hip
things gotta have product placement we
gotta do we got God have windows phone 8
we got to have the Ford you know it's
gotta have it you know so a great
premiere you know for the area were
excited the show's back on you know I
just I can't wait to it's going to
happen please let us know what you
thought of tonight's premiere let us
know you think's going to happen in the
future you know chata sub as always you
can find this at thank yo calm but also
gonna check out our videos here on our
youtube page just think hero pro and
also find us on twitter is going to chat
with us you know Mike Denness myself
we're at think hero i'm personally at
griffin de now that mr. Michael Alexis
we also have a Facebook page at
facebook.com slash think hero fans
you